Our galaxy is in the middle of NOWHERE.
We’re regular joe’s, rockin' the boat...
at The Redneck Galaxy Club.
The universe seems chaotic, but it’s actually
not as bad as you think…
There is quite a bit of order.
20-percent of our universe is made of filaments...
like these.
The other 80-percent of it… are voids of
mostly empty space.
Superclusters, galaxies, planets, galactic
dust… everything is either densely-packed
into a filament or in a lonely void.
And some researchers are saying our Milky
Way galaxy might exist smack-dab in the middle
of one the largest voids of them all.
We could be living in the middle of nowhere!
Which is unusual for a galaxy!
It’s like we’re living in the boonies
and most other galaxies are in cities...
We’re so alone...
As scary as this may sound, the researchers
seem to think it’s not that big of a deal.
It sounds like because we’re further away
from the filaments, our night sky is a bit
darker, but other that, not much else is different.
There is something big that could come from
this study though (if it’s proven)…
Our universe is massive and it’s constantly
expanding.
Just the observable cosmos reaches about 46
billion light-years!
But astronomers have been struggling for decades
to figure out the exact rate of expansion
-- also known as the Hubble Constant.
There are two methods to measure this -- to
look at nearby bright stars that are moving
away from us, or to look at the Cosmic Microwave
Background radiation (left over from the Big
Bang) and see how fast that is moving.
It’s actually a big debate, because these
two methods don’t give us the same Constant.
This new research suggests that because we’re
in a void, gravity is pulling us closer to
the filaments and that movement could be messing
up calculations with the nearby stars.
So to put it all together -- if we do live
in the cosmic boonies, the CMB method of analyzing
the expansion of the universe is probably
more accurate!
So living out here is fine.
I like country music anyway.
So now that you know a bit more about what’s
inside our universe, don’t ya wanna know
about what’s outside of it?!
Check out this video here.
Real talk though, would you rather live in
the city or the country?
Let us know down below in the comments, be
sure to subscribe if you haven’t already
and we’ll see you next time on Seeker.